hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week and a whole lot more fumbles to
come your way uh this week we're talking
about cmmc control cm.l
2-3.4.6 and play the principle of least
functionality by configuring
organizational systems to provide only
essential capabilities
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here in on-call
compliance solution where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so
in cmmc control cm.l
2-3.4.6 employ the principle of least
functionality by configuring
organizational systems to provide only
essential capabilities I have to say
this is actually a really important
control so I know I make a lot of jokes
my videos all right and we'd like to
have a lot of fun around here but
seriously
that's right uh this one is actually
serious so again uh only let your users
do what they need to be able to do in
order to do their job that's a lot of
doing but in all seriousness people
should not be able to do things that
they're not authorized to do in your
system all right it's very very
important control don't give people more
access than they need to have okay uh it
gets them into trouble it gets you into
trouble uh just ask the people at the
Pentagon I mean like not to make a joke
about it but like what are people doing
with access to hundreds of thousands of
classified documents all right don't
give me access there's the control
you're required right here in the law to
do that so look people should only have
access to what they actually need to
work on currently in their jobs all
right the principle of making sure that
team members only have access to what
they need to perform their currently
assigned job duties and keeping that
access relevant and up to date is so
important when it comes to information
security and so under and it's so
understated too you know again like I
get it I.T guys you know just keeping
the system up and running is a lot of
work but man if you if you've got more
than like 20 30 users on you've got to
look at like that like I'll tell you
like in our company when we got past 12
we're like hey the marketing people no
offense guys shouldn't really have
access to like all kinds of really
important stuff about how we operate
like they should have access to
marketing stuff all right and that's at
12 people I walk into companies all the
time with hundreds of employees who
literally have access to everything even
the CEO stuff it's just sitting there
okay so again yes I know it's time
consuming to go peel back permissions
especially in large networks but here's
what's going to happen if you don't
someone's going to get permission of
stuff they shouldn't have and then
they're going to your competitor so
which one do you want yuck all right and
on call it's one of our top priorities
with our clients to really lock down
systems
to only what is needed for everyone okay
so again if you've got job a you should
only have access to what's needed to do
job a much better that way now let's
check out what this what the assessors
are looking for on this one how to make
them happy
first they're looking to determine if
essential system capabilities are
defined based on the principle of least
functionality so number one is have you
defined your system capabilities based
on what it is that person needs to be
doing so lots and lots of ways to do
this you can do it with organizational
units you can do it with security groups
you can do it with completely separate
systems here's a great example if you
run a security information event
management system which of course you do
because you're compliant right
and if not you're going to call us right
exactly uh not everybody needs an
account there all right only the people
who actually need to access that system
to do their job should have access that
system if I was given a sample answer
I'd say something to the extent of look
authorized users are only granted the
access and capabilities required to
complete currently assign job duties
based on the principle of lease
functionality authorized users are
restricted via permissions Group Policy
system access controls from any
capabilities not authorized by the
information owner in the it ticketing
request system access be granted uh from
whoever the information owner is so
again the idea is the information owner
makes the request the IT team executes
everything's documented a ticket and
then someone can finally be let in to
access what they need to
all right second assessment Point
determine if the system is configured to
provide only the defined essential
capabilities uh the system is tested on
a daily basis by both users and it
administrators to ensure that only
essential capabilities exist for all
users as a part of daily operations the
itus and cyber security policy requires
all system users to immediately report
unauthorized access capability
so if you are struggling trying to
figure this stuff out or
if you just need extra bandwidth okay
we can help because we work with defense
contractors just like you who've had
this DeForest nist itar cmmc compliance
stuff dropped in their laps like a
seagull on a sunny day we teach you how
to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps great areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance as your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit cmmc
complianceeekers.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as your compliance nerds
roll it out until the next compliance
tip my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
let us know what you'd like to know more
about when it comes to information
security and compliance and I'll see you
on the next one
foreign
[Music]